et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Brice Hortefeu bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous depuis européens
membres des républicains on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour
Brice Emmanuel Macron est en visite des
tas de deux jours au Pays-Bas hier il
prononçait un discours sur l'Europe sur
la souveraineté européenne on va y
revenir mais au cours de ce discours il
a été interpellé Hué interrompu par des
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites et qui demandait plus de
démocratie est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron est
un président politiquement empêché par
cette réforme
en tout cas évidemment le calendrier ne
le sert pas
déplacement en Chine déplacement dans la
foulée
au Pays-Bas et alors que notre pays est
confronté à l'évidence à une crise
sociale qui est une crise sociale
importante
en tout cas je sais pas s'il pouvait
modifier le calendrier il a déjà modifié
pour la venue du roi d'Angleterre dans
notre pays peut-être que s'il avait
modifié son déplacement la date de son
déplacement au Pays-Bas elle aurait été
mal compris mais en tout cas la réalité
là vous savez parfois
la baraka fait partie de la bonne
gestion selon une expression connue et
donc là contestablement elle a tourné
cette chance bon sur sur le fond en
revanche l'attitude de ceux qui l'ont
interrompu d'abord c'est incorrect c'est
peut-être que la correction ça compte
aussi dans la vie de tous les jours
comme dans la vie publique et surtout
sur le fond c'est faux il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas eu de remise en cause de la
démocratie dans notre pays à l'occasion
de le débat et moi je suis partisan de
de cette réforme et ce qui a été utilisé
ce sont les articles prévus par la
Constitution et je rappelle et je
rappelle que notre reconstitution qui a
été adoptée en septembre 1958 a été voté
par
80,69 % des Français peut-être que ceux
qui l'ont interrompu hier ne le savez
pas
cette opportant d'utiliser le 49-3
le 49-3 c'est une procédure qui a été
utilisée à une centaine à sans reprise
d'ailleurs depuis 1958 donc sans reprise
ça peut pas dire que c'est exceptionnel
que c'est inédit c'est historique je
comprends qu'on veuille de certes pour
certains affirmer cela je comprends que
dans les médias on soit obligé
systématiquement de dire que cet
historique est inédit mais la réalité ce
n'est pas ça sans reprise depuis 1958
est-ce que cette crise sociale ne
fragilise pas quand même la France et la
position de la France sur la scène
internationale quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé hier au Pays-Bas
oui bien sûr mais nos voisins immédiats
sont surpris moi je suis donc au
Parlement européen je veux vous garantir
que des employés de du Parlement
jusqu'au élus mes collègues d'autres
pays ils sont assez stupéfés pourquoi
sont-ils stupéfaits et ils sont
stupéfaits parce que les Belges les
Espagnols les Polonais les Roumains sont
déjà 65 ans parce que les Allemands les
Italiens le Royaume-Uni qui faisait
partie de l'Union européenne et ce sont
des les Danois sont passés déjà enfin
son programmée pour aller à 67 ans et
nous on est là à dire 64 ans c'est
beaucoup bon et donc je vous le dis vous
ne posez la question je vous dis ça
stupéfine nos partenaires même si
parfois les mécanismes sont un petit peu
différents mais ça se stupéfit parce que
si l'on prend la mesure d'âge en 2030 si
la loi est appliquée et nous serons
le pays d'Europe dans lequel on partira
le plus tôt à la retraite c'est ça la
réalité de cette loi est-ce que dans ce
contexte de crise sociale en France il
était judicieux de faire les
déclarations qu'Emmanuel Macron a fait
vis-à-vis de la Chine vis-à-vis des
États-Unis est-ce que c'est le bon
moment pour afficher une troisième voie
comme il l'a fait en tout cas ça a été
visiblement mal compris mal compris par
nos alliés américains et vous comprenez
que c'était mal compris par
nos alliés et les membres de l'Union
européenne avec un argument qui n'est
pas un argument qu'on peut balayer d'un
verbe d'un verre de main c'est que les
États-Unis
sont en là pour aider l'Ukraine et que
s'il n'y avait pas l'aide des États-Unis
l'Ukraine aurait naturellement déjà été
envahi et submergé par la Russie donc
cette déclaration était maladroite même
si une erreur politique
coûter chacun s'exprime avec ces mots
mais
si je dis c'est une déclaration
maladroite même si il y a assez vrai une
tradition française et notamment une
tradition vis-à-vis de la Chine puisque
vous le savez c'est la France qui a été
un détour premier pays au monde à
reconnaître la Chine puisque c'était une
décision qui était à l'époque qui a été
discuté bon mais pour autant il faut
naturellement pas adresser le signal
d'un abandon sans rien dire sans rien
faire sans rien opposer à une île qui a
une île qui est d'abord qui compte 23
millions d'habitants qui a été
d'ailleurs bombardé à l'époque il y a
très très longtemps par la par la France
mais qui est une île qui est très
importante dans cette zone indopacifique
on va parler de la réforme des retraites
comment Emmanuel Macron peut-il sortir
de la crise que connaît le pays comment
vous la qualifiez cette création on est
dans une crise politique on est dans une
crise démocratique comme le dit Laurent
Berger
en tout cas
la réalité c'est que nous sommes dans
une impasse aujourd'hui on est dans une
base sociale puisqu'on est sorti de la
crise des gilets jaunes pour tomber dans
le chaudron des retraites une impasse
économique je pourrais vous donner tous
les chiffres ou les connaissez enfin il
y en a un qui moi impressionné
énormément c'est le déficit de commerce
extérieur 64 milliards alors que
l'Allemagne a un an et demi avait 172
173 milliards d'excédents donc c'est
très révélateur de l'impasse économique
un passe financier puisque l'on sait
aujourd'hui que notre dette avoisine les
3000 milliards ça c'est dit répéter à
juste titre mais d'abord ça n'aimait pas
grand monde mais surtout j'insiste sur
ce chiffre de 3 milliards vous allez
comprendre pourquoi parce que
l'intérêt de notre dette de ces 3000
milliards en deux de en 2022 par rapport
à 2021 a augmenté de 13 milliards
et 13 milliards c'est globalement ce que
l'on attend comme effet positif comme
économie de la réforme des retraites
regardez la différence avant des
retraites 13 milliards ça met la France
à feu pas à feu et 13 milliards
l'intérêt de la dette personne n'en
parle vraisemblablement vous qui êtes
des spécialistes de l'actualité
spécialiste de notre la situation de
notre pays vraisemblance ce chiffre vous
ne connaissiez pas et pourtant vous
voyez ce sont deux chiffres identiques
et regarder la diversité des
conséquences et puis une dernière
impasse c'est l'impasse politique
l'impasse institutionnel parce que quels
sont les deux leçons à tirer de cette
crise et de leçons première leçon c'est
que le Président c'est que dans notre
pays
majorité relative ça signifie pas de
majorité du tout
vous employez le mot majorité relative
non ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité et la deuxième leçon ça
concerne ma famille politique et ça lui
donne donc une responsabilité bien
particulière la deuxième leçon et c'est
que 100 LR rien ne peut se faire c'est
ça que l'on retient la première des
leçons où vous énoncez ça veut dire que
le président a tort aujourd'hui encore
d'espérer trouver des majorités de
textes par tête pour la suite de son
grand canin non je pense que la suite de
son quinquennat est préoccupante parce
que observer là aussi la situation ce
qui était une situation d'ailleurs
inédite j'ai fait référence à la
Cinquième République il y a quelques
instants mais là cette situation oui
elle était inédite puisque nous sommes
en début de quinquennat
et cela donne l'image d'un quinquennat
finissant déjà nous sommes au début et
la perception c'est image finissante
possible dans ce quinquennat je pense
que le danger
qui est devant nous c'est l'immobilisme
par crainte c'est tout vous dites la
capacité à rebondir derrière la réforme
des retraites dire qu'il y a pas mal de
textes qui sont au programme notamment
la loi immigration vous pensez que ça va
être très compliqué
c'est un très bon exemple
je sais pas si on va parler de
l'immigration mais je pense que c'est il
faut naturellement une initiative
importante en matière de gestion et de
maîtrise des flux migratoires puisque
nous sommes en plein désordre en réalité
migratoire aujourd'hui et la première
mesure qui est prise à l'issue de aphas
l'issue pendant cette crise des
retraites et bien c'est d'annoncer que
c'est reporté saucissonnés enfin j'ai
pas très c'est une erreur pour vous j'ai
pas trouvé en tout cas moi je sais qu'il
y a besoin d'une loi migratoire
au Sénat comme c'était fin mars est-ce
que c'est fin mai je n'en sais rien mais
en tout cas il faut une loi migratoire
il fallait pas la diviser en deux comme
ça a été fait comme ça a été proposé par
le gouvernement
si c'est une ficelle pardon on
comprendra très vite que c'est une corde
en réalité parce que si l'idée c'est de
prendre un texte pour plaire un peu à la
gauche et puis ensuite pondre un autre
texte qui serait susceptible de nous
plaire davantage je pense que pardon la
ficelle est un peu épaisse mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette ex parce
que la droite la droite ne voulait pas
le voter en l'état ce projet de loi
immigration vous comprenez
là alors passe au fond du sujet c'est ça
votre votre question
moi je pense si vous voulez que le on a
besoin aujourd'hui non pas d'une d'une
évolution mais d'une rénovation complète
de la politique migratoire pourquoi une
raison c'est pas simplement pour faire
chez vous parce que nous sommes dans une
situation bien particulière sur ce sujet
si vous observez la réalité faut pas
être dans le déni il faut être lucide et
on peut dire les choses avec lucidité
posément raison mais en même temps
clarté quelle est la clarté la clarté
c'est que d'abord jamais il n'y a eu sur
le territoire français autant étranger
la part des étrangers dans la population
française elle est passée en 10 ans de
7% de la population à 10,3 vous voyez ça
donne un élément deuxièmement jamais
nous n'avons délivré autant de types de
séjour 320 330 je vous rappelle quand il
y a 10 ans c'était
192.000 jamais autant dit de surchas il
la responsabilité de l'État c'est un
choix du gouvernement ça jamais il n'y a
eu autant de demandes d'asile
156.000 c'est là aussi c'était il y a 10
ans pour prendre la référence 55000 vous
voyez bien là 3 jamais il n'y a eu
autant de mineurs isolés vous pouvez
prendre des chiffres différents et des
chiffres qui sont officiels stricto
recensés et c'est de 14000 comme ça et
c'était 5000 il y a 10 ans
parce que pour vous comprendre pourquoi
quoi il y a une nécessité c'est que
selon les propres chiffres du ministère
de l'Intérieur le nombre de clandestins
tiers de ceux qui sont venus sur notre
territoire sans nous demander notre avis
sans nous demander notre autorisation en
faisant en quelque sorte un bras
d'honneur et bien ceux qui s'écland
destin le nombre selon le ministère
intérêt est entre 700000 et 1 million
donc vous voyez il y a une réalité
démographique de migratoire qui montre
que nous sommes en plein désordre et
donc nous les républicains nous sommes
le parti de l'or donc nous soutiendrons
une loi qui remettra de l'ordre mais
dans la loi immigration il y avait une
partie sur le travail les patrons
français qui ont du mal à recruter
demande une part d'immigration légale
pour trouver de la main d'oeuvre dans
une période où le chômage est en baisse
ils ont du mal à recruter il faut pas
leur répondre
j'ai été ministre de l'Immigration et
ministre de l'Intérieur et l'immigration
et c'est normal qu'on commet des erreurs
on tâtonne moi j'ai pas attendez pas du
tout avoir la science infuse et au
contraire c'est un sujet grave que j'ai
que j'ai découvert et j'espère avoir un
peu contribué à à régler sous l'autorité
de Nicolas Sarkozy et le
mécanisme qui est envisagé puisque
maintenant il y a plus de texte je sais
pas le mécanisme qui est envisagé
c'est une procédure quasi automatique de
régularisation et moi je vous le dis
toute procédure automatique suscite un
appel d'air j'ai lu d'ailleurs des
tribunes en carrière sur des sujets très
honnêtement la périple qui conteste cela
ne connaissent pas la rétention on fait
des régularisations individuelles c'est
cela la réalité je vous donne un exemple
j'avais été confronté à une situation de
cette nature celle que vous décrivez
dans une restaurant qui était dans une
vallée d'Alsace trouvez pas de cuisinier
j'ai régularisé quelqu'un donc de
manière individuelle après une examen
approprié précis un engagement la
personne venait venait avait un titre de
travail une autorisation de travail
titre de séjour mais avec des
contreparties des engagements qui
étaient faits et parce qu'il n'y avait
personne d'autre mais tous mécanismes
qui seraient un mécanisme général est un
mécanisme qui conduira à un appel d'air
inéluctable donc il faut refuser pour
revenir à la situation politique vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que l'une des
leçons attirées c'est que sans les LR
rien ne peut se faire est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut que les LR passent un
accord de gouvernement qu'il y a une
coalition
la réalité je l'ai dit il a déjà
quelques quelques mois j'ai eu que
d'autres
avancées une idée la réalité c'est que
la balle était dans les mains d'Emmanuel
Macron il fallait qu'en 2022 il est la
lucidité de constater que il avait
besoin de partenaires et c'est pas du
tout ce qu'il a fait alors moi j'ai
cartonné ce que j'avais dit coalition
non parce que coalition
ça veut dire ralliement individuel et
honnêtement l'expérience je citerai pas
le nom mais j'ai bien en tête et
l'expérience montre que des ralliements
individuels que ce soit d'ailleurs à
gauche ou à droite il y a un côté
souvent souvent misérable pas toujours
mais souvent assez misérable et ça c'est
pas le meilleur côté de la politique et
c'est pas vraiment ce pourquoi moi je me
suis engagé en tout cas il y a déjà bien
bien longtemps en revanche c'est ce qui
s'est passé en 2022 ce que maintenant il
faut un accord de gouvernement entre les
républicains et je pense que je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron a loupé le coche donc
je pense qu'il a été il a été de fait
preuve d'une absence totale de lucidité
il avait deux opportunités de première
opportunité c'est au lendemain de son
élection immédiatement de tendre la main
avec des engagements de fond
naturellement parce qu'il y a des points
très précis sur lequel ma famille
politique est utile puisqu'elle apporte
des positions claires et il y avait une
deuxième possibilité c'est au lendemain
des législatives pas une possibilité
deux possibilités il n'en a saisi aucune
des deux qui aurait dû faire au
lendemain des gestatives faut
comprennent bien nommer en premier
ministre LR à Matignon c'était ça je
pense que c'était effectivement ça pour
lui une des possibilités
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans la
même situation mais si demain il annonce
la nomination d'un Premier ministre LR à
Matignon est-ce que ça pourrait résoudre
une partie de la crise politique que
vous venez dénoncer ce qu'on pourrait
faire avec Paris et la bouteille bon
donc non c'est pas comme ça que
malheureusement la vie politique
fonctionne aujourd'hui la position des
républicains elle est très simple et je
pense qu'elle est utile et c'est de
prendre la tête
de position chez les républicains il y a
ceux qui sont tentés d'aller vers un
accord de gouvernement et ceux qui
disent non on est dans l'opposition
jamais quel est votre niveau de quand un
texte est utile au pays il faut que les
républicains naturellement le
soutiennent quand un texte est nuisible
au pays il faut naturellement que les
républicains le contestent et quand les
républicains le peuvent ils doivent
apporter leurs solutions ne sont pas
toujours d'accord sur la nocivité ou les
bienfaits dans le texte ce qu'on a vu
sur la réforme des retraites j'étais
certain que vous alliez évoquer ce sujet
vous avez raison mais la réalité c'est
pas celle-là non plus et la réalité
c'est que si vous prenez la position
précisément des républicains sur les
retraites mais vous constatez quoi vous
constatez que le groupe est l'air du
Sénat président
était une quasi unanime et vous
constatez qu'à l'Assemblée le groupe
présidé par Olivier Marleix était à 70%
favorable c'est ça la réalité bon donc
alors je comprends bien qu'on mette en
valeur construit mais si je veux aller
plus loin sur ce même sujet la position
des républicains pardon sur cette
réforme des retraites a été utile elle a
été utile puisque c'est là où on a on
s'est préoccupé de la pénibilité on a
élargi les critères de pénibilité on a
évoqué les carrières longues on a
ont abordé le soutien à la politique
familiale et je pourrais comme ça
continuer une liste et vous nous dites
vous nous dites c'est trop tard
aujourd'hui pour un accord de
gouvernement même si Emmanuel Macron
souhaite nommer un Premier ministre de
droite le nom de Gérard Larcher
circulent par ici
j'ai lu j'ai relâché à ce stade
d'aspirer qu'à une seule fonction celle
de sénateur des Yvelines et donc
par définition je crois et je mets je
vous dis à deux Emmanuel Macron avait
deux occasions il a pas laissé passer
ses deux occasions est-ce que les
républicains ont un avenir en dehors de
tout accord de gouvernement on voit les
sondages qui testent les républicains
qui testent le nom de Laurent Wauquiez
il est à 5%
vous êtes suffisant c'est normal vous
l'évoquez me faisait suffisamment averti
je vais pas vous rappeler la litanie des
sondages depuis le début la Cinquième
République par la journée je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle simplement que
François Hollande était à 3 % bon il
s'est bien retrouvé président de la
République donc tout ce
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
signification non en revanche il y a une
question et c'est que les républicains
doit pouvoir répondre à
arriver avec une idée simple et claire
c'est son sommes-nous utile si nous ne
sommes pas inutiles bien sûr les
électeurs nous diront merci au revoir
même si nous appartenons à un courant de
pensée qui a donné à la France de des
présidents de la République nous avons
des racines de de responsabilité de
crédibilité nous sommes le parti de du
gel de cuisine s'inspire en grande
partie du gaullisme valérus car destin
de Jacques Chirac des Nicolas Sarkozy
donc mais la question c'est est-ce que
nous sommes utiles si nous ne sommes
inutiles oui nous disparaîtrons si nous
sommes utiles alors à ce moment-là nous
pourrons effectivement répondre pour
être aux attentes et donc renaître
est-ce que c'est renaître ou disparaître
est-ce que pour être utile il faudrait
pas que le parti soit d'abord uni et
est-ce que c'est pas Laurent Wauquiez
aujourd'hui de donner cette ligne même
s'il a pas de fonction officielle à la
tête du parti de Denis cette ligne
d'unité des républicains
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'entend aussi
peu finalement sur un moment où crie ou
la France traverse une crise
relativement grave connaissez La
Fontaine
un verre de la fontaine dans le
vieillard et ses enfants qui dit que
toute puissance est faible si elle n'est
pas unie alors c'est ça la réalité et
la réalité c'est que l'Union n'est pas
la garantie du succès mais c'en est une
des conditions donc moi j'en appelle à
l'unité de ma famille politique mais je
suis très confiant sur la responsabilité
et à donner une ligne aujourd'hui
on connaît notre socle nous sommes une
grande famille politique qui est
par exemple il y a de forts divergence
quelqu'un que je respecte que j'apprécie
qui parfois tendance effectivement à
marcher sur la ligne jaune mais tant
qu'il ne l'écrase pas il y a pas de
souci donc en réalité
mais vous connaissez mais sur le fond là
je réponds avec une boutade mais sur le
fond je pense sincèrement que la
politique c'est une affaire d'addition
pas de soustraction donc il faut
additionner les talents et vous citez
Aurélien Pradier mais on a la chance
d'avoir de notre politique beaucoup de
talents quant à Laurent Wauquiez quant à
Laurent ok moi j'en suis convaincu il a
d'ailleurs personne ne le remet en cause
la compétence l'expérience l'autorité
pour prétendre au plus haute au plus
haute fonction votre candidat naturel
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est le cas pour
moi c'est le candidat naturel et je vous
le dis je suis convaincu que le moment
venu on sera semblera autour de lui en
tout cas c'est ce que j'ai fait ton
silence est-ce que son silence sur la
réforme des retraites ne l'a pas
affaibli mais je vous lis d'abord
il y a deux choses premièrement sur les
retraites pardon de vous le dire non
vous qui a été très clair il a dit qu'il
l'a dit publiquement et d'ailleurs s'est
adressé on s'adressant à vos confrères
donc on peut pas dire que ça soit en
catimini s'adresser à la presse donc il
a dit qu'il était favorable à une
réforme parce que nous allons dans
l'impasse si on le réforme pas mais il a
dit que la méthode était sans doute pas
la bonne ce qui me paraît de bon sens
télé pour affirmer cette position elle a
dit il a dit devant il l'a dit devant la
presse donc encore une fois il l'a pas
dit cacher masquer derrière un rideau
était divisé où il fallait trancher et
Laurent Wauquiez a un calendrier et
vous vous posez la question son silence
je vous dis que son silence
d'aujourd'hui prépare sa parole
est-ce qu'il a prévu de parler
prochainement
par rapport à l'histoire je sais pas
quel à quel moment vous situez le
prochainement avant après les
européennes
je pense qu'il est sans doute s'il me
demande mon avis s'il me demande mon
avis je lui ai conseillerais plutôt
après les élections européennes là il a
en terme parce que on terminerait un
cycle
se déclarer immédiatement après les
européennes
ça ça lui a salué
si pour être la soit très clair je
résume mon sentiment je pense que là en
Vautier le candidat naturel qu'ensuite
on se rase que je suis j'espère je suis
convaincu qu'on se rassemblera autour de
lui et que la discrétion qui est
aujourd'hui la sienne permettra son
expression fortement et vous pensez pas
que son absence aujourd'hui risque de
lui être reproché au moment de cette
déclaration de candidature en disant à
un moment crucial du pays vous n'avez
pas été là pour porter la parole de
notre parti politique je peux
recommencer dans un autre langue ou un
patois mais je vous redis ce que je vous
confiance que je viens de vous dire
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité la grande pagaille à Toulouse
c'est à la Une de La Dépêche Christelle
il y a des petits problèmes de métro
hier du coup ça crée une pagaille à tout
le sel et une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Christelle merci d'avoir été
notre invité on passe au club d'État